time for our scene and unseen segment
where we reveal the story behind the
headlines for that we have a special
celebrity guest star actor and director
Robert Davi joins us Merry Christmas
Robert and you've apparently came
costumed I love it uh Robert a woman
named Mary Jane cops has cornered the
market on overcoming phone phobia she
calls herself the phone lady get this
she charges 480 dollars an hour for her
Services she says Jen's ears were never
taught how to speak on the phone
she teaches them how to overcome their
fear by giving them advice like this
let's
um
video of taking care of your voice your
voice is your brand I'm going to talk to
you a bit about the importance of
viewing all your phone calls as meetings
we want to use this discovery call
to display our confidence if there's
background noise it's a distraction on a
phone call
Robert the average age children get
their phones is 11 years old why would
they be afraid to use something they've
had since elementary school
because they don't phone they text
and a lot of adults have the same kind
of phobia arrayment they're afraid of
talking on they've lost that art they'd
rather text and this is a I think it's
it's for tick tock it's for Instagram
it's for bming it's for other kind of
apps but they don't speak on the phone
they don't call up and say hey what are
you guys doing I have kids they're
texting yeah you go to a restaurant
adults are texting back and forth
it's difficult they've lost that look at
Gen X needs a lot more training on other
things well they didn't just how about
human interaction I mean it's human cues
it's it's vocal cues that is totally
lost when this is all you're using look
for 480 bucks an hour forget the phone
she needs to be the cursive and manners
lady as far as I'm concerned here are
some young people we spoke to about this
phone crisis today
some of my friends are afraid to talk to
like if we're ordering a pizza or
something so
I usually do it for them because I you
know I need that practice and it's a
good skill to have I would rather text
because it's easier so yeah I would say
also decline calls because why not just
text me it's you know quicker and easier
mostly I usually text
um but phone calls are not like trouble
for me if someone calls me I'll answer
and I'll talk to them but I'm not
usually to make a phone call
Robert W you you've directed you've
acted your whole life it just occurred
to me could this be why acting is
degraded and degrading in our culture
today because people don't have you
can't replicate uh emotions and and uh
little sensitive moments and details
that you've never observed in life
they are preparing us for artificial
intelligence whereby we have a plug in
our brains and we lose we lose human
interaction as you said with the acting
classes there's Skype classes there's
there's the kids aren't getting up and
doing scene study like they did for
decades with you and I did with Stella
Adler and Lee Strasberg and the rest of
them those those uh few and far between
and um it's endemic of the whole society
we have a system look at you call up
a service
you don't speak to a human being you
have 45 prompts to get through to
somebody maybe who's a human being that
can speak English yeah no it's all meant
to delay human contact Robert I need to
move on director James Cameron has been
out promoting his new film the sequel to
Avatar that nobody asked for he spoke to
Esquire about his past use of guns in
films saying I look back at some of the
films I've made and I don't know if I
would want to make that film now I don't
know if I would want to fetishize the
gun like I did a couple of Terminator
movies 30 plus years ago in our current
world what's happening with guns in our
society turns my stomach I'm happy to be
living in New Zealand where they just
banned all assault rifles and quote
Cameron went also went on to say he cut
about 10 minutes of gun play from his
newest movie now Hollywood should take
note Robert this is one way to get James
Cameron to cut his movies down but it
strikes me this is like Dolly Parton
decrying blonde wigs and cleavage he
made his money on gun play every movie
Terminator A True True Lies all of this
stuff had gun play it feels like
Latter-Day virtue signaling to me what
say you
yes well I mean I used to ride
motorcycles with him and Arnold
Schwarzenegger back in the 90s and stuff
during Terminator and afterwards and
True Lies era and he was a gentleman he
was a nice man and I think it is the
virtual singling signaling that is
happening look Raymond there's a crisis
in Hollywood whereby
white men white showrunners white
writers white directors
older guys are not getting hired they
want younger or people of color
so there's a fear I'm sure in terms of
saying I don't want to feel out of touch
with this gen Z generation that's
whatever is happening out there in
society and I think that's part of the
issue there's a fear of uh and there has
to be there can also be because I don't
know his current state of being but
there can also be a revelation in terms
of you know what's the violence in
Hollywood films what it portrayed and I
say what about the gaming yeah gaming is
even worse the gaming is an active
participation of violence to a non-human
object that's pretending to be a human
yeah that kind of mystifies you know so
yeah no you're absolutely right and the
gaming is far more pervasive than and
and influential than films kids are
spending hours immersed in it
communicating with each other through
these gaming platforms
um you know the other thing that that he
said Robert Cameron said was that he
regretted the toxic masculinity of his
films in the past now in the year that
saw Top Gun as the number one movie in
the country it's an odd time to pick a
fight with masculinity isn't it
uh it's uh the sign of the times
it's an unfortunate very unfortunate
thing that's happening I talked to a
friend of mine my new neighborhood here
in Tampa Bay he's an ex-green Beret guy
wonderful person I won't mention his
name but highly decorated
he told me that in the military now this
toxic masculinity that women who cannot
do the job
let's say for men they have to do eight
deadlifts a woman can just do a half a
thing and then when they get in
situations a woman was jumping out of
the plane and she couldn't pull herself
up to untangle the the uh the um you
know so it it's a it's a problem Robert
I wish I had more times but we will
discuss toxic masculinity in all its
varieties when we return in the new year
happy New Year Robert great to see you
and thank you also a singer don't forget
I'm also a singer okay hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else